c'est vrai que vous m'aimez bien le blog
oui mais non et aux montagnes ou
versements la canourgue l'aude commence
à cette vidéo ne va pas être sérieuse
bref il est temps de vous parler de la
soupe aux choux film culte aux français
de 1981 avec louis de funès et jean
carmet et jacques villeret
sans oublier notre bonne vieille france
in l'objet de la vidéo
christine deux jours mais avant de
commencer bon allez je me verse un canon
ce film fait certainement partie de mon
top 3 de mes films préférés
derrière lyon professionnels et
interstellar alors oui ce n'est pas du
tout le même registre mais ce film
ferrer m'attendrit me fascine je voulais
réellement faire une vidéo
alors va-t-on au sujet et je suis désolé
de vous prendre la tête sur un monument
du cinéma français mais considéré ça
plutôt comme un hommage ce qui est le
cas alors vers toi un canon avec moi et
puis en haîti part comme vous le savez
claude ratinier dit le glaude était
marié à la france in sa femme
cependant la malheureuse est morte à ses
60 ans et le glaude vie donc depuis plus
de dix ans sans sa chair francine
cependant coup de théâtre l'adorent et
ramène france hymne à la vie et la fait
revivre à ses 20 ans enfin ce n'est pas
vraiment la denrée carla francine est
carrément déposée par un verseau donc
ses camarades qui ont fait revivre la
france y un an d'où duo la question et
de quoi est constitué francine
techniquement c'est une vraie question
il faut savoir que sur oxo la planète où
vit la denrée on ne mange que des
minerais autres sels minéraux ils ne
mangent pas comme nos sur terre de plus
ils peuvent vivre jusqu'à 200 ans
mais sur leur planète il n'est pas
mentionné que la denrée puisse vivre 80
ans sur terre mais le glaude lui peut
vivre 200 ans sur oxo c'est là le coeur
du problème la france in est morte à
l'âge de 60 ans est resté dix ans dans
la tombe
elle se fait miraculeusement réanimer à
l'âge de 20 ans cependant peut-elle
vivre jusqu'à 200 ans
car si elle a été ramenée et ce à l'âge
de vingt ans par les habitants d'oxo
elle doit avoir leur avantage c'est sûr
a contrario c'est une terrienne
et vie sur la terre donc voilà peut-elle
vivre jusqu'à 200 ans ou bien dans les
80 comme un humain de l'époque il faut
savoir qu'elle est refabriquer à son
jeune âge grâce à la technologie d'oxo
et leur savoir donc elle n'est plus
comme un humain normal où on s'est prise
de tête là laissez moi me verser un
dernier canon pour la route du coup la
france il si on suit la logique du film
elle serait de nouveau une menace
quelqu'un normal landes a cependant déjà
niveau caractère ce n'est plus la même
mais cela reste une écart détails qui
nous laissent elles sont revenir d'oxo
là où elles furent animés métamorphosé
sincèrement je pense personnellement que
la france in et donc sur les mains
donc elle vivra comme un humain lambda
mais vivra plus longtemps ou est-ce que
tu aurais pas fini ta vidéo cassettes de
merde
si si c'est bon j'ai fini manger soit
vers ce mois un canon 1 qu eux betty
comprend type averse - cannes en audio
le canon comprendre aussi que c'est pas
seulement du pilat mais que c'est de
l'amitié
[Musique]
à
je
il
[Musique]
ouais